KARTHIK KASHINATH: Extreme
weather is changing.
There's more extreme rainfall,
heavy flooding, forest fires.
There's the radio
signature, [INAUDIBLE]..
Being able to predict these
extreme events more accurately
is kind of the big challenge
that we're facing right now.
There's 100 terabytes of
climate data every day
from satellites, from
observations, from models.
So climate data is
a big data problem.
We need things
that are fast that
can sift through all of that
data rapidly and accurately.
And deep learning is almost
perfectly poised for problems
in climate science.
THORSTEN KURTH: A lot of NERSC
users are using TensorFlow.
It's one of the more
popular frameworks.
We use TensorFlow
to iterate quickly
over the different models,
different layer parameters.
For this particular
climate project,
to create the deep
learning model,
we started from
segmentation models,
which have proven
to be successful,
for example, our satellite
imagery segmentation tasks.
And then we use TensorFlow
to enhance the models
until we found a set of
models to perform well
enough for this specific task.
But for the volume of the
data, complexity of the data,
the network required
14 teraflops.
So if you want to do
this on your workstation,
it would take months to train.
MIKE HOUSTON: To really
tackle these problems requires
the largest computational
resources that
are available on the planet.
So systems like the
Summit supercomputer,
it's two tennis
courts in total size.
I mean, this thing
is state-of-the-art.
It's a million times faster
than your common laptop.
3.3 exaflops.
Just imagine what you
do at your workstation,
but now imagine having
27,000 times that power.
We can do that now.
THORSTEN KURTH: We were
surprised how good it actually
scales.
1,000 nodes, then 2,000 nodes.
5,000 nodes.
MIKE HOUSTON: This
was the first time
anybody's ever run an AI
application at this scale.
Instead of having the
climate scientists figure out
how to write high
tune code, they
could express things in a
very natural way in Python,
in TensorFlow, and get all
the high performance code
that most HPC people are
used to within TensorFlow.
KARTHIK KASHINATH: We're
now entering the space where
AI can actually contribute
to the predictions
of these extreme weather events.
MIKE HOUSTON: When you combine
traditional HPC with AI,
you can tackle things we never
thought that we could tackle.
Fusion reactor research,
understanding diseases
like Alzheimer's, cancer, right?
That's incredible.
THORSTEN KURTH: We've shown
that with the hyperactivity
framework such as TensorFlow,
you can get to massive scale,
and you can get
awesome performance
and accomplish your goals.
KARTHIK KASHINATH: Genetics,
neuroscience, cosmology,
high energy physics, that is
immensely exciting for me.